uh John meath he's a visualization
engineer at Texas Technologies and he's
going to tell us about Vegas Fusion they
get let's give him round clause and take
it away
all right uh thank you everyone for
coming I really appreciate this
opportunity to talk with you all about
this work to scale Altera visualizations
with Vega Fusion
to quickly introduce myself my name is
John Meese I'm a visualization engineer
at hex I'm the Creator and maintainer of
Vega fusion and a contributor to Altair
in past lives I've worked with plotly
and anaconda on plotly dash data Shader
Hollow views and a couple other projects
in the pi data visualization ecosystem
so I've been thinking about
visualization in Python for for quite
some time now
here's an outline of what we're going to
cover today
first why I think Altair is a great
option for exploratory visualization in
Python
then I'll talk through some significant
limitations of Altair
related to data set size and accessing
transformed transform data
I'm going to walk through how Vega
Fusion solves these limitations with a
couple of demos
we'll look briefly at how big a fusion
works and then I'll mention some
additional applications of the core Vega
Fusion technology
all right let's jump in
so why Altair
there are six areas I'm going to touch
on
first altaris API is declarative so you
spend your focus on how data should be
mapped to various elements of your chart
rather than focusing on writing lots of
imperative steps to build up a chart
step by step
its API is composable the individual
Concepts that you learn can be freely
combined to build up sophisticated
charts from simple components
Altair includes a suite of built-in data
Transformations which reduces the need
to jump back and forth between pandas
and your charting Library as you're
iterating on visualizations
one of the most unique features of
Altair is that it includes support for
interactivity in a way that gives you a
lot of control over how chart
interactions behave
Altair's popularity is growing
and an alternate 5 which is going to be
out shortly is going to make Altair even
better
this section is going to include include
several examples that reference this
car's data set from the Vega DSS package
throughout the examples this data frame
is going to be named cars underscore DF
it has 406 rows and here are the columns
that we're going to use there's the
miles per gallon for each car the number
of cylinders the displacement
horsepower and the country of origin one
of Europe Japan or USA
our first example of Altair's
declarative API is this faceted scatter
plot
we're plotting horsepower versus miles
per gallon and faceting by country of
origin
in a declarative visualization API like
Altair is the code that you write
specifies the requirements for the final
chart the details of how to build a
chart that satisfies these requirements
is left up to the library
we'll start by importing Altair
and then wrap the car's data frame in an
Altair chart
method chaining syntax is used to say
that we want to plot circles Altera
calls plot Primitives like circles
points lines and bars that calls these
marks
alter uses the concept of encoding to
map data columns to Mark properties like
position color and size here we're
saying that we want the X position of
the circles to correspond to the
horsepower column
the Y position to correspond to the
miles per gallon column and the origin
column to correspond to the subplot row
now let's contrast this declarative
implementation of this plot with an
imperative specification in matplotlib
so in an imperative visualization API
like matplotlib you specify the
individual steps required to build up
the chart
this yields more control oftentimes but
it up to the visualization author to
ensure that the steps that you choose uh
result in a chart that matches the
intended requirements
let's walk through this example first
import pipelot and then before anything
else we need to compute the set of
unique origin values so that we know how
many subplots we're going to need
then create a figure with one subplot
Row for each origin value
we'll Loop over the subplot axis and
origin Pairs and then filter the input
data frame to include only those rows
for the given country of origin
create a scatter plot using the
horsepower and miles per gallon Columns
of the filter data frame
and then set the x and y axis labels
then set the x and y axis limits to run
from 0 to the global max value of
horsepower miles per gallon if we don't
set the axis limits this way then each
subplot would have independent access
limits in the wooden wouldn't line up
now looking back at the Altair example
you can see that it's declarative nature
means that Altair can handle a lot of
low-level details on its own it
automatically determines how many
subplots are required it automatically
labels the axes to correspond to the
encoding columns and it automatically
computes the axis ranges and
synchronizes them across the subplots
all this is not to say that imperative
apis like matplotlibs are bad they
typically offer more low-level control
but this control comes at the cost of
being more cumbersome for exploratory
use
as a side note math uplibs is a great
Foundation to build on and there are
several declarative visualization
libraries that are built on top of
MacBook lab including Seaborn and plot9
so that's how Altair's API is
declarative
next I'm going to talk about
composability
so what does this mean the way that I
think about it in the context of Altair
is that if you know how to accomplish
feature a and you know how to accomplish
feature B then you can be confident that
you can combine these two features
together and Altera will do the right
thing
here's a simple example
in the left column we have a
specification for a scatter plot of
horsepower versus miles per gallon where
the points are colored by the country of
origin
Altair automatically adds a helpful
color Legend that's labeled origin
the center column
in the center column no color encoding
is provided and the points are sized
based on the engine displacement column
now Altair produces a point size Legend
where the Border color matches the
default blue used in the chart
composability means that we can be
confident that you can use the color and
sizing Coatings together and Altera will
do the right thing
now the points are colored by country of
origin and size by displacement both
Legends are included and nicely laid out
you can notice also that the size Legend
has switched from Blue to gray to
indicate that the color and size are now
varying independently
this is a really simple example but this
composability property Works throughout
Altair and once you get used to it it
gives you a lot of confidence in using
the API
our next Altair has built-in support for
data transformations
we're going to look at a simple example
where this is useful we're going to
create a bar chart of the average miles
per gallon for each cylinder count for
only the USA origin cars
to create this chart in matplotlib we
first use pandas to filter the data
frame to only those rows of origin USA
then Group by cylinders and compute the
mean we'll reset the index to create a
cylinder underscore means data frame
which has one row for each cylinder
count
create a bar chart from the cylinder
means data frame and then set the axis
labels and title
this approach works but there are some
downsides the same column needs to be
specified in multiple places if you want
to change the x-axis column from
cylinders to something else you need to
modify the code in these three places
or if you want to change the y-axis
column from miles per gallon to
something else you need to make these
three updates
and if you change the mean aggregation
to say a median you need to make sure to
modify both the pandas aggregation and
the y-axis label to make sure they're
consistent
here's how the same chart can be created
with Altair
I'll wrap the car's data frame in an
Altair chart and then use the transform
filter method to keep only those rows
with origin USA
the expression then create a bar Mark
and encode cylinders that's the X
position
and for the Y position use the
expression mean miles per gallon
finally set the title to USA cars
by incorporating data Transformations
into the chart specification this way we
remove the duplication and can Now
quickly edit the X column y column and
chart aggregation and everything will
stay consistent
this approach also allows Altair to
automatically label the y-axis with the
aggregation that was used in this case
the mean
Altera includes an expressive selections
framework which can be used to build up
sophisticated interactive charts you
have full control over how selections
affect the visual appearance of marks
and how they filter the underlying data
selections are part of the chart
specification itself and so the
interactive behavior is self-contained
and doesn't require a running python
kernel
this means that interactive charts work
in save notebooks and when charts are
embedded in websites without python
all other interactive python libraries
that I'm aware of require the use of
python callbacks to configure their
interactive behavior and so they require
running a python kernel in order to
operate
here's a simple example of an
interactive bar chart with cylinder
count on the x-axis and average miles
per gallon on the y-axis the chart
supports interval selection and a
horizontal red rule is overlaid with the
average miles per gallon of all the
selected cars
and Altair's popularity is growing as of
this month Altair is the second most
downloaded python visualization library
from Pi Pi behind only matplotlib
there are a lot of great resources
available online for learning Altair and
a growing community
the first release candidate of Altair 5
is now available this is the first new
major version of Altair in several years
and includes some exciting new features
there are improvements to the method
chain and syntax to make it more
ergonomic
exporting charts the static images like
SVG and PNG has been dramatically
simplified it no longer requires an
external web browser or node.js
installation or selenium or anything
like that
there's improved support for grouped bar
charts and support for non-pandas data
frames like polars was added using the
data frame interchange protocol
so I hope I gave you a quick taste of
why I think Altair is a great choice for
exploratory visualization but on its own
it has some significant limitations
to outline this section we're going to
look at the limit that stock altered
places on data set size
we'll talk about how it's not possible
to access the transform data in Python
now look at a workaround mentioned in
the Altair documentation and explain why
it's not a full satisfactory solution
this section is going to include several
examples that reference the 1 million
row flights data set named flights
underscore DF this includes columns for
the flight date and time the number of
minutes the flight was delayed and the
distance of the flight in miles
let's create a histogram of the flight
distances we'll wrap the first 5000 rows
of the data frame in an Altair chart and
I'll explain why 5000 in a moment
then create a bar Mark and encode the
distance column as the X position
Bend into approximately 20 bins
and then use the count of entries per
bin as the Y encoding
this works well and creates the plot
shown here
but now instead of just the first five
thousand rows we'll pass all one million
rows into this chart
this results in an Altair Max rows error
so Altera performs its data
Transformations like histogram binning
and aggregation in this case uh performs
those in in the browser so it needs
access to the entire input data set in
order to perform those transformations
but to avoid crashing the browser with
too much data by default Altair imposes
a 5000 row limit and raises this error
when the limit is exceeded
here's another limitation
let's go back to the example that only
uses 5000 rows to avoid the max rows
error exactly how many flights are there
between 200 and 400 miles
from the chart we can see that it's a
little bit less than 2400 but there's no
way to extract this exact number from
the chart to use and downstream
processing in Python
again the reason for this is that Altera
is performing these data transformations
in the browser and so the results are
not readily available in Python
a workaround for both of these
limitations that's described in the
Altair documentation is to move the data
transformation steps outside of Altair
and then pass the transform data into
the chart
to demonstrate this we'll use the numpy
histogram function on the distance
column of the flight's data frame to and
this will produce the bin edges and
counts
and we use these to build a distance
underscore DF data frame which now
includes one row for each histogram bin
this solves the max rows error because
the data frame will pass to the Altair
chart now has only 10 rows instead of a
million
it also solves the problem of accessing
the transform data since now these
values are readily available in python
as a data frame for Downstream
processing
we'll wrap this distance underscore DF
data frame in a chart and create a
rectangle Mark using the start and end
edges and the bin count for the height
this gets Us close but it's still not
quite right
so numpy's histogram function uses the
Min data value as the first Edge in the
histogram and then uses the max data
value as the final Edge
and then evenly divides the range into
10 bins by default
altera's approach is a bit smarter and
choose its human friendly bin edges that
align with the axis ticks
we could get a closer match by passing
an explicit range a number of bins to
the numpy histogram function but
Computing this range a number of bins is
not trivial to do the way Altair does
also because we perform the data
transformation outside of Altair we lost
the automatic x-axis labeling
um and so here it has the start Edge end
Edge instead of what we wanted
so this approach can work but it's sad
to lose so much of what's great about
Altair when your data set exceeds 5000
rows or when you need access to the
transform data in Python
this approach is also incompatible with
the charts that filter data in response
to interactive selections so we couldn't
use this approach with the average miles
per gallon by cylinder count example we
saw earlier in the video earlier
now let's talk about Vega Fusion Vega
Fusion solves these limitations so you
can take advantage of everything that's
great about Altair even as your data set
size increases and the transform data is
required in Python
Vega feature provides three main
features
the first is the big effusion mime
renderer which automates this
transformed in Python workflow that we
just talked about by automatically
pre-evaluating data transformations in
the python kernel instead of the browser
Vega Fusion provides a function to
extract transform data from an Altair
chart so it can be used in Downstream
processing in Python
and finally Vega Fusion provides a
widget renderer which is specifically
designed to support charts that perform
interactive data transformations in
response to selections
let's look at the mime render
the biggest mind render is enabled by
importing Vega fusion and calling the
Vega fusion.enable function
when enabled data Transformations and
altered charts are automatically
pre-evaluated in the python kernel
before being displayed
unused data columns are also removed
automatically to reduce the size of the
data so it gets loaded into the browser
this approach makes it possible to scale
most Solitaire charts to millions of
rows as long as they include some form
of aggregation
here's the same distance histogram that
raised the max rows error with stock
Altair with the Vega Fusion mind render
enabled it renders quickly and without
an error
this approach reuses the existing Altair
chart rendering infrastructure so it's
compatible with every Jupiter based
environment that already supports Altair
so this includes Jupiter notebooks
Jupiter lab Visual Studio code and
online notebook services like collab hex
notable sagemaker and and many others
Vega Fusion also provides this transform
data function that accepts an Altair
chart and Returns the transform data as
a pandas data frame
here's an example what this looks like
for the flights for the flight distance
histogram
we can see that the return pandas data
frame contains 12 rows one for each bin
and contains columns for the each bin
Edge and the histogram count this data
frame can be used to easily look up the
count and number of records for a
particular distance range
and the Vega Fusion mime render and
transform data function together they
completely remove the need to rewrite
Altair's data transformations in pandas
here's a quick demo of what this looks
like in a notebook workflow I'm going to
use hex for this example but again this
works exactly the same way in any
jupyter-based notebook environment that
supports Altair
first I'll load the 1 million row
flights data set using the pandas read
parquet function
then display this data frame using a
table View
and with this table view we can see that
the data frame does in fact have a
million rows
next we'll wrap this data frame in an
Altair chart and create a histogram of
flight distances
this results in the max rows error as
the data set has more than 5000 rows
then import make a fusion and call the
Vegas enable function to and then
redisplay the chart and now displays
another place here quickly without an
error and to access the transform bin
counts we use Vega Fusion's transform
data function and this produces a data
frame with one row per histogram bin and
columns for the bin edges and counts
now this is the vacation widget render
rather than pre-transform Data before
rendering the chart the Vega Fusion
widget renderer maintains a live
connection between the kernel and the
browser and transforms data in response
to selections
this provides full support for
interactivity and but to enable this
live connection the widget renderer
relies on a custom Jupiter widget
extension so unlike the mime renderer
the widget render is only compatible
with compute environments that support
third-party Jupiter widgets
to enable the widget render import Vega
fusion and call the enable underscore
widget function and then create and
display the chart as usual
here's a demo what this looks like in a
notebook environment I'm going to use
jupyter lab for the in this case as the
widget under requires support for custom
third-party widgets
first look at the interactive cross
filter example from the Altair
documentation this uses the Altair
selections framework to implement cross
filtering across distance delay and time
histograms
this example uses a 2000 row flights
data set to ensure that everything fits
comfortably in memory in the browser
now we'll jump over to Jupiter lab and
we'll enable the widget render and then
load the 1 million row flights data set
using the pandas read parquet function
I've copied the exact chart
specification from the gallery and
updated it to feed in the 1 million row
data set
even with a million rows cross filtering
is smooth and responsive each selection
update is sent to the Vega Fusion
runtime in the python kernel to refilter
and re-aggregate the selected data this
way the full million row data set is
never sent to the browser
and for the final demo I'm going to push
the scale a bit further here we're using
a data set with information on 10
million New York City Taxi rides
the left chart is a histogram of trip
distances
the middle chart is a fine-grained heat
map of Taxi pickup locations the Altair
selections framework is used to re-bin
and re-aggregate the pickup locations in
response to the pan and zoom events
it also supports interval selections the
selections on all three of these charts
are linked by cross filtering using the
Altair filter transform and the
selections framework
the right chart is a heat map of the tip
to fare ratio bin by hour of the day and
day of the week
so how does vacation work
first we're going to look at Vega Lite
and Vega and the role that they play
and then show how they're used in the
standard Altair architecture
and then we'll look at how Vega Fusion
modifies this architecture to support
scaling Altair charts to large data sets
Altair relies on two web-based
visualization libraries Vega Lite and
Vega Vega light is a high level
visualization Library written in
typescript it accepts Vega like chart
specifications and then compiles them
into Vega specifications
Vega is a low level visualization
Library written in JavaScript it accepts
Vega specifications and renders them in
the browser using SVG or canvas
both of these libraries were created by
the University of Washington's
interactive data lab under the direction
of Jeff here
Altair's primary job is to provide an
ergonomic python interface for building
Vega light Json specifications
these they go like Json specifications
are passed to the browser for conversion
to Vega and then rendering using SVG or
canvas
Vega Fusion works at the Vega
specification level
the big effusion planner performs a deep
analysis of the Vega chart specification
to identify data Transformations that
can be evaluated on the server which in
this case is a python kernel
these server eligible Transformations
are extracted into a server Vega spec
that is then processed by the Vega
Fusion runtime
the client Vega specification with the
data Transformations removed is passed
to the standard Vega JavaScript library
for rendering
for interactive charts displayed using
the widget renderer messages are sent
back and forth between the Vega and Vega
between Vega and the Vega Fusion runtime
to maintain the interactivity of the
original Vega specification
so quick notes on the Technologies the
Vega Fusion is using
both the planner and the runtime are
written in Rust in the case of the
widget renderer the planner is compiled
to webassembly to run in the browser
the runtime implements Vega's data
Transformations using the Apache Aero
data Fusion Library
which is the rust library and it's
compiled to python using pi03
to learn more about writing python
libraries in Rust there's a talk
tomorrow by Carl Katie that looks really
helpful it's called Nine rules for
writing python extensions in Rust
and finally the messages exchanged
between the runtime and the client are
in binary protocol buffer format and
take advantage of Apache arrow for
serializing data frames
in the last few minutes I want to
quickly touch on features of Vega Fusion
that extend beyond scaling all tear
charts the wrap pandas data frames
we'll look at Vega Fusion support for
polars
and support for duckdb
and how big a fusion can support
graphical chart editors that produce
bigalite
so Polaris describes itself as a
lightning fast data frame library for
rust in Python polars has quickly gained
popularity as a faster alternative to
pandas that also supports larger data
sets combined with Altair 5 support for
the data frame interchange protocol Vega
Fusion adds support for building all
tear charts directly from polar's data
frames and evaluating the data
transformations in the python kernel
without converting through pandas
this integration makes all Terror and
Vega Fusion a great visualization
solution for polars users and also makes
polar as an attractive alternative to
pandas for Altera users
so bigger Fusion converts Vega
Transformations into SQL queries
internally these queries are usually
evaluated by the embedded data Fusion
runtime
but we've recently added support for
specializing the generated SQL for
evaluation and other SQL query engines
like ductdb
ductdb is an in-process SQL query engine
and database that provides bindings for
a wide variety of languages including
python
additionally while it's not all wired up
yet we have the foundation in place now
to connect Vega Fusion to a wide range
of SQL databases and data warehouses so
if you're interested in using Vega
fusion with a database like postgres or
a data warehouse like snowflake please
reach out and let us know love to talk
to talk to you about that
and because Vega Fusion works at the
level of Vega specifications it can
support Vega and Vega light use cases
Beyond Altair for example Vega light is
a great Target for graphical chart
editors and Lego Fusion can be used to
scale these editors to support much
larger data sets by moving their data
transformations to a server
this is exactly how the graphical chart
editor Works in HEX if you're building a
web application that produces Vega or
Vega light specifications please reach
out I'd love to talk to you about how
Vega Fusion could fit into your
architecture to scale to larger data
sets
to learn more check out the project
website at vegafusion.io for the
document the documentation and their
blog
see the beta Fusion GitHub project under
the hex Inc GitHub org for the Vega
Fusion code base issue tracker and
discussion board and if you're
interested in what we're building stars
are appreciated
and finally follow the project on
Twitter at Vega Fusion underscore i o
for release announcements
thank you very much
[Applause]
if there any questions I'd be happy to
talk more about it
otherwise lunches
lunch is next that's good
yeah I think
I think
I'm asking the specialist because a lot
of the examples that you showed were
maybe a little more sophisticated than
what I'm curious about which is
you know does it behave well does
everything you said hold true for like
doing a simple like
to interact and plop with a huge number
of
so as long as it includes some sort of
aggregation it does if you're doing like
a scatter plot then nothing is
aggregated then you're still going to
run to the limits of data set size in
the browser so Altera and Vega
um I think a light they're not like GPU
accelerated for rendering like lots and
lots of scatter points that's not a case
that they're very well optimized for yet
but for things like histograms or like
that fine-grained heat map that I showed
for the taxi data set there you're doing
some aggregation even at the pixel level
that helps a lot and the aggregation can
happen happen in the server
I will post them I'll probably tweet
them out on the Vega Fusion Twitter page
if you want to follow that it's probably
the easiest way to get them out there
oh
I'll do that shortly
uh-huh
jury here and you experience that these
large-scale visualizations
is everybody moving to rust like what's
your how is rust changed what you're
able to do
you can
tinkering with these things for so long
um I mean I see the the option now of
writing python libraries in Rust is I
see it as a new Evolution of how things
used to be written in Fortran I missed
the Lord but how in older libraries were
written in Fortran and then wrapped in
Python by writing in Rusty I've accessed
a lot of nice libraries a nice package
manager
um and there's uh the Apache Aero
library in rest is really really helpful
and so that was a nice Foundation to
build on so
um I mean I have worked on a lot of
python libraries that were intending to
be very fast in the python like data
Shader where you do
a lot of um work with number and other
tricks to get a lot of performance out
of python those work work really well
rust is another approach to doing that
where you can do everything at a native
level and then provide a nice python
wrapper around it and that's the
approach that I wanted to try in writing
Vega Fusion
question
thanks
everyone